[Music]
Runk I got
cancelled my son is cried every single
day for 3 years and it's crazy because
over the last 3 years I've cried every
single day for different reasons you
know he's like I'm hungry I'm like I
want my [__] career back
[__] doing all this therapy she said
to me well that's no surprise you're a
comedian I said what do you mean I know
you think you like to do standup because
you like to make people laugh when
people laugh that means that they accept
you and you need that and that's when I
was like you're a [__]
[__] I'm just a guy and I'm just trying
to do better okay they don't want you to
change that's the truth I got back on
stage and people were just like what the
are you but I fck typed so [__]
hard
okay listen to me listen to me all right
my special grow or Die My fifth special
is available for pre-order now until
midnight it is available now chia.com I
have self-released this in the gangster
way I put it out there and you are able
to purchase it now pre-order order at a
certain price it's $8 and then at
midnight the special comes out when the
special comes out on chia.com it will be
available for a little bit of a higher
price so you are able to get it now for
uh less so go to
csia.org the special grow or die it is
the thing I am most proud of
uh in my career this special above any
other special uh I don't I honestly it
was the hardest thing I've done and I am
more proud of it than I am of any other
work that I've ever done so go support I
put this out on my own chia.com and I'm
so excited for you to see it and uh it's
an hour and 8 minutes I believe it's
it's it's a little more than an hour and
uh I you know I don't I don't like when
people say blood they put their Blood
Sweat and Tears in it but I did put my
Sweat and Tears in it I
suppose uh no blood but go check it out
um and
uh I love you man chris.com I'm just I'm
super happy it's out and uh I'll let the
work speak for itself so without uh
further Ado welcome to the new
uh EP actually let me say something
before this because I'll just put the
link uh under the thing on the comments
that be the pinned comment so go click
that link which is chris.com anyway
whatever I'm excited about it and um I
hope you like
it and now without further Ado my uh the
next episode here we go the next episode
of
[Music]
congratulations
hey it's uh it's a good day dude yep
it's a good day and I just realized I
have a tag that's sticking in the side
of my thing that's so
annoying I like I don't
understand the I guess you have to have
a tag to know what size and all that
[__] but like don't have that it pokes
in the side right and you never notice
until you're out and nobody has a
scissors
it's all good it's all good my babies um
this is the whatever episode it's 300
and something I don't even know I can't
even believe how how many episodes we've
had and Calvin came in earlier obviously
and messed with all the levels on the
headphones cuz we couldn't hear anything
and then we noticed that all of them
were turned down to a certain uh level
and that was definitely that Calvin that
did that because he comes in here and
pushes the buttons and my gosh I only
feel love about that you know if anyone
else were to ever do that I would get I
would get mad but Calvin's really kind
of opened me up and made me think about
things in a different way dude I tell
you right
now this weekend this this weekend that
we just had the past weekend
was dude so I was a little sad on like
Thursday I think you know some days you
just wake up and you're like okay and
the whole day you're just all
right okay I guess I'll go to bed and
and see what happens tomorrow the next
day wake up and you're like all right oh
okay you know um the weekend was just
Bonkers connected Bonkers good great
mood good attitude and I'm just like
dude
what is this what it's going to be like
today not bad now it's Monday right now
and I'm just like where's the bad mood
coming now I'll let you in on a little
secret dude I've been taking satala pram
for 17 years okay I didn't know this but
apparently what my psychiatrist said not
my therap not my psychologist my
psychiatrist I got so
many ah it's hard to deal with
things she said that they have a she
said sorry to use this term but a poop
out date now I don't know what it is but
I love learning about poop so what is
that she says there is a
time limit on these ssris on these
medications I didn't know that and I've
probably I'm well past the poop out date
I'm well P past the the medicine going
Kut okay and I'll tell you why think
that because I switched I went to do a
little bit of a switch on the medication
now do I wake up anxious sometimes
because of it I think yes is it because
the therapist is it because the
psychologist said maybe it would happen
and maybe it's psychosomatic and she
shouldn't have mentioned it yes it could
be right but it's happening I wake up a
little bit anxious and it's all good
okay and then I get really good as the
day progresses on Thursday have a little
bit of a Saturday and then Friday and
Saturday and Sunday super connected now
did I start with 10 milligrams of Prozac
yeah he did and then a week later did he
go to 20 milligrams of Prozac yeah he
did and then a week later did he go to
30 million proac yeah Secrets out he did
okay and while he was doing it what was
he weaning off
ofr yeah he was okay and was it 40
milligrams of cell yeah it was and then
was it 30 it was and then was it 20 yeah
it was and now would at 10 so now we're
doing 30 and 10 and I'm just like oh all
right need to make that
louder and and it's just
like May is this what life is like
because I'll tell you what no buzz no
nothing right look I've taken a VI ANS
before I know what it feels like it
feels like you do a relic Coke all right
because it's basically riddle which is
basically Coke all right yeah can I pay
attention when I did it oh yeah but when
I took viance before I'm like remember
when I took it when I went on the boat
there was an episode where I talked
about how I went on a boat I took a
viance because I thought that maybe I
was going to have a rough time being on
a boat with a bunch of people because I
didn't want to be on a first of all
didn't want to be on a boat second of
all didn't want to be with a bunch of
people and we were going to marry the
two oh God so took a five ants and I was
the life of the I was the lot and when I
say I was the life I mean I was the life
of the party
okay so I know what that feels like it
feels like you do a rail of coke okay
all right now I don't know what Coke
smells smells like feels like but I know
what viance feels like and I did it felt
like I did a rail of coke okay which is
what I think what Coke is but whatever
anyway I don't feel like that I feel
like my intrusive thoughts are still
there but they didn't matter that much
you know like I still think about you
know if I walk down this Alleyway maybe
later on I'll get cancer but I go like
this whatever maybe it won't be for a
long time I go like
this there's the alleyway if I walk down
here ah maybe my mom will get throat
cancer ah she'll be all
right so I'm just like all right so
maybe I've been living wrong for like 5
years with the I don't know when the
calan pooped out and look this is not
this is is a health and wellness podcast
but this is not a medical podcast I'm
not trying to be like yo you guys should
take Prozac yo you guys should take you
know think but think about your SSR man
if you've been doing that [__] for 15
years wof you might be in your poop out
date and I hope that this right I I was
saying it to my therapist I was saying
to my couple's therapist I got so
many I have so many therapist so I was
saying to my my couple therapist oh God
I have so many
dude and
um and I was telling her I was like I
really hope it's a prog Prozac and she's
like well you know maybe it is but don't
worry if it's not we'll get there and I
go all right you
know and then she was like look in your
wife's eyes and tell her why how you
feel and I was just like oh anytime you
got to do that in Coupes therapy if
you're in couples therapy look Coupes
therapy is great because you know what
that whole book Men Are from Mars women
are from Ikea whatever the hell it is
um like
it's unbelievable how much it's hard to
be on the same page with anyone now take
into a account a woman right if you're a
man if you're a woman then a man right
so therapy couples therapy is good I do
it now do I want to do I go like this
every single time we got to go do it
yeah now afterwards do I feel better
half the time half the time I feel worse
but then I start to feel better I guess
so what happens
is therapy's fine when I'm talking to
the therapist cool sitting next to my
wife all good but dude when I got to
[__] turn when she says why don't you
now look at Kristen look in her eyes and
I
go this is exactly what I don't want to
be doing dude I love looking in her eyes
but I don't want to be like looking in
her eyes and have her looking in mine
and be talking that that that step is
fine the look in her eyes is fine the
her looking in my eyes are are good good
great love that let's stop it right
there because after that the me talking
about my feelings
part oh no thank
you so CHR why you look in her eyes and
tell her how that makes you feel as a
man no thank
you but you got to do it because you're
there right the [__] costs whatever it
costs I don't know
they just Char me every [__] month
and um I did it and she's like doesn't
that feel nice and I'm like I guess dude
but it's so [__] uncomfortable man
you know you
know G like dude I was watching Ice Age
earlier and like the [__] woolly
mammoth was like took the spear from the
caveman guy and he was going to stab him
and [__] and then the and then they had
the kid on the top of the woolly mammoth
and was like look here's your kid and
they thought they were never going to
see each other again but now they are
and now the kids's walking and the dad
wasn't even there but the animals taught
them to walk and so it's
like all right but then they play the
music and I'm like oh [__] man like that
really makes me if I let it
feel if I let
it I can feel very very deeply about
that but dude I don't let it do I no no
because it's [__] Ice Age dude
because I'm not going to let my feelings
pour out of me looking at a [__] CGI
woolly
mammoth
right but then I'm like
man is that a problem like it feels so
uncomfortable sometimes when you listen
to certain look I know I talk about how
I don't like music sometimes look I
heard a song that I used to hear in high
school and it was too much for me dude
and I go like this
oo maybe it's nice but I'm not there yet
and I know I'm still really young 43 but
like dude it was like really [__] me
up and I can't really listen to
Something's blocked off whatever dude
you
know I'm glad you're with me thank you
for listening
because who knows where I would be
without you guys and without therapy and
without I think probably my life would
be roughly the same name except for well
I think without therapy I'd probably be
[__] underground um so uh
but whatever dude I keep it cool at the
gym I was at the gym and I was killing
it okay as I do some some guy comes up
to me and says hey man what's the
progression how did you get to where you
get to uh with that exercise because
what I was doing is I was going down on
one leg
single leg touching my other knee to the
ground and Rising back up now that's
very hard to do it has a lot to do with
balance and I was doing it with 40 PB
weights oh God damn it dude but I was
though right no lie no
cap stop the cap don't we have
that somewhere right stop the
cap
no stop the cap so uh yeah dude no I was
I was legitim imely going down on one
leg touching my other knee to the ground
holding 40 lbs stop the C and
um and the guy comes up and he says like
dude can I ask you what's the
progression like what's it like to get
to there and I said well you started
with no no no weight and he was like
well that's interesting because it must
make it a little bit harder but then you
can put and I tell him all about it and
he goes like I walk out I'm like dude
guess what that dude asked me about uh
advice hey dude the icing on the cake he
was
Fit Stop the C dude he was fit okay so I
go and then I look at him and he's fit
and that's my [__] confidence man
just growing up like I took a mushroom
and I'm wearing [__] red overalls
just loving it man you know and I go and
I text I immediately text my wife and
our friend together in a group text dude
fit guy really I fit guy asked me for
advice and they go oh my gosh okay guess
what dude the next day I'm working out
same dude comes up to me ask me about
for more advice and then I'm talking to
him and I realize oh he's just kind of a
[__] crazy
guy oh he's talk because he's talking to
everybody so I go oh [__] he's not
talking to because he wants to advice
he's talking to me because he's running
from something oh for [__] sake dude
but he was fit dude and I'm going to
hold on to that man I'm going to hold on
to that cuz it made me feel so
good
um I don't
know oh yeah I got this [__] tattoo
dude added to
it my mommy hates
it but dude it's fine cuz I'm [__] so
yaded up I really am a he's got a throat
pie he's got a bit of a throat piece I
mean it adds to the collection of it
under his chest on his chest but he's
got a bit of a throat piece hey nothing
hurt as much as the ribs did the throat
piece HSE hey Chris did the throat piece
HSE hey Chris did the throat PE hey
Chris did the throat pece
hurt yeah did but not as much as a
[__] ribs dude
uh I don't care man you know how you
know what dude you know what they say
tattoos I I I I listen I read this thing
I know exactly what a tattoo feels like
it feels like a cat is scratching you
over and over and over again
read that somewhere can't stop thinking
about it maybe maybe the proac isn't
working all that well but
um it is what it is man and I honestly
um my contacts have been my contacts
have been [__] up ever since we've
been we had couple Sur because I had to
focus on the
computer
uh but we had our Halloween party we had
our Halloween party I'm sorry if you
weren't invited I can't remember all of
my friends you know that's what I hate
about inviting
I don't I'm supposed to remember all my
friends my wife is like who do you do
you want to invite who do you want to
invite and I'm
like just you know who and she's like
yeah but and then throughout like the
three weeks leading to the party what
about and I'm like oh yeah yeah and then
I say uh a few days before party how
many people are coming and she said I
like 60 and I go oh for [__] sake dude
60 I got to hide all my
[__] right I got to put a [__] bunch
of stuff in the safe 60
people you know what that means there's
going to be at least seven people I I
don't know who they
are I don't have a clue dude there
were there were actually six people I
had no idea who they
were oh dude how infuriating [__]
blood red mad would this make you well
first of all I we I put Calvin a bed
in the middle of the party and I had to
lay with him until they fell asleep cuz
it was loud and I did do that cuz I'm a
good dad I love doing it and I walked
out as soon as I walked out I bump into
Clark Kent with a Superman like he's got
the glasses on open shirt Superman I go
like
this I've never seen this person in my
life okay I walk downstairs he starts
then I see him again he starts talking
to me I don't know who I'm talking to my
wife go and I say who's that she said oh
that's my friend's uh husband I said
who's your friend she said my friend I
know her from Instagram I go well you
don't even know the
friend good thing I hit all my [__] I
don't need a man who's faster than the
speed [__] faster than locomotive
stealing my you know what I
mean and so they're very sweet though
actually I want to be their friends
they're very sweet but so this is the
blood red mad part David Sullivan dude
Fathead goes like this hey man how how
how lit are you trying to get this party
because I got some friends that could
come by and I and I but I don't even
know he text here's the thing he didn't
text me that he texted my wife that and
he knows I would have just went [__]
I would have sent him that emoji that
red circle with the line through it or
that red X just I would have it would
have been
that dude I walk by the island I see
David's text from my wife's phone it's
open by the way okay and it says how lit
are you trying to get I got friends that
could come to the party too and my wife
says bring him and I so I'm like oh this
[__] is trying to backo it dude
he's trying to [__] Hollywood agent
it he's trying to get because he knows
I'll say no he knows I'll be like I
don't want these [__] you know
she already said yes so now I'm pissed
all right but it's cool because I was
Bonkers connected this weekend and I'm
all good but so he comes over okay we're
chilling I put Calvin in a bed now it's
11: and I come out of the the [__] uh
room it's 11: bump in a Clark Kent we're
chilling for a bit I go Hey where's
David my wife says I don't know David's
not there anymore and then four people
show up at my house and my wife says who
are they and I say I don't know so I'm
like
great we're getting robbed okay and then
Brent finally is like Brent Moren is
like hey what's up and I'm like you know
who they like oh these are David's
friends I'm like oh so David these are
the people that David invited dude these
are the people that David invited and
David already left dude David left and
other people came that he invited bro I
lit him up on the text and go I
go he says man you said they could come
they they showed up at 12:30
dude a tall guy with mushrooms
came he had mushrooms dude he gave
people
mushrooms
that's that's fine dude do your shrooms
but like dude David be here he was just
like a vampire you
know I can't
dude but I was too I was I was honestly
I was too H I was too happy but like it
was just like so annoying
man hey what's up a guy hey what's up
don't dude if you go to a house you
don't know somebody you don't say hey
what's up you go hey man how you doing
nice to meet you I'm [__]
whoever I don't like being in other
people's
houses I don't it it's like it's not
familiar to me one time I I was looking
cuz we were looking at cuz we're
building a house so we were looking at
houses that people that people uh that
contractors built
and he was like the contractor took me
to the house this was a few months ago
took me to someone's house that he built
and they were
home I said come on in and they were so
foreign that I don't even know what
country they were from it was some it
wasn't it was just like hello how do you
how are you and I'm just like all right
we come around
wherever okay and then the contractor's
like look at this look at
this look at that see these are the
attention to details that other
contractors won't get look at that look
at it lights how they're all lined up
look at that and then this originally
was like this and I [__] made it like
that just right there but if you're
going to have you know and I'm walking
by and the lady's like hello and I'm I'm
just
like thank you for letting me and I go
thank you for letting me you know come
in and look at the house and she goes
like this
and I'm
like can we all just like chill a little
bit I don't need to be in this house I
could look at it show me pictures
bro you hear those dogs I'll tell you
what my dogs have been went to a kennel
they went into a kennel like uh um
however many months ago when we went to
it was in September October November uh
two months you still got to do that by
the way I [__] I I always got to
do and um they they got kenel cough from
there which is you know they go I have
here so they
go like so much and here's the deal
kenel cof is something that you can keep
catching I have four dogs so when one
person when one of the dogs is getting
over it the other dog gets it they've
had it for for [__] since September
the beginning of September 2 months
there's always a dog one of my dogs is
going That's How It
Ends this is this is the whole thing the
Ken
COV and my friends come over they're
like is this [__] dog okay and I'm
like it's fine dude he's fine like
you're not worried about it I'm like no
that that's more annoying than the
[__]
thing and the big dog Cooper when he
gets it it's so
loud we wake up at 8 o'clock in the
morning oh the
whole nine times
dude I love life life rips I love
life I didn't put on deodorant
today but I tell you what I don't
usually need to but
sometimes sometimes late at night I'll
[__] like put my my armor around my
wife and I'm
like are you eating a sandwich in here
and it's just because I didn't put
deodorant
[Applause]
on buy Berg water drilled from icebergs
on amazon.com go to my page if you want
to purchase a 10-word ad or shout out
holler. bab christalia
um everyone keeps asking me this am I
gonna get a a drake for all the dogs
jacket
and I'm looking at it right now and the
answer is no you know pre you could
pre-order that just like my special go
to cr.com
people really
rock really rock Drake merch like it's
like Banana Republic like not like look
merch is merch you go to a little yach
show you're wearing the thing that
little is from Lil yatti show and you
know it you know what I'm saying like
you're like I got this shirt on from the
L yachty show and everyone's going to
look and they be like oh you're at the
little yti show and they go yeah oh you
got that yeah whenever you look at merch
and you know the artist that the
person's wearing for the merch you go
like this oh oh right dude
Drake his merch people wear it and
they're I've been a Tonto bro people
wear it and they're like it's part of my
outfit that's so
dorky because it's not I mean I guess it
is its own brand like October's very own
wow the headphones in the [__]
tag the headphones you
know
uh uh wow too many words on the jacket
dude
what does it say AAR game faith my later
truth oh these are the the track album
these are album tracks the
tracks I like that he did this
though there's oh there's also uh grower
die merch that's available by the way
and it's sick dude I'm like
Drake sick in
it I'm not getting that jacket though I
got too I live in LA I got I I got I got
some cool jackets but I don't need I
don't need to wear them but I am going
to the east coast so maybe I will start
wearing them flavor Phil of Sayang the
national anthem
say can you
see Fergie is like finally by
the why he's not a singer
dude like watch how my uncle Vinnie do
it he's just
[Music]
not
what so
[Music]
proudly we I mean way better than I
thought he'd be honestly at the
TW I mean doesn't know when the word
ends
ging
who
wow and bright
stars kind of nailing it honestly
[Music]
the killed it dude how about how the
people who wrote this song if they could
Flash Forward and see how this guy's
dressed singing
this they would just be like you know
what they go they go like this they see
him going they go like
this
for the
R so
bad it's good when he gets to the lower
register he's
good doesn't know when the
[Music]
word wow some of the basketball players
are laughing what dicks you
know oh oh they didn't by the way they
didn't [__] the best part I'm sure he
ruined the rockets red glare part right
is that what rockets red flare what is
it I don't know I'm I'm not patriotic
and The Rock and and the rockets red of
air with bombs with bombs bursting in
air gave true to the
night but the [__] guys were still
there
[Music]
say does that star
spangled I I I get different with
[Music]
it
um
shout out to flavor flave doing it
though I wanted
um dude how crazy is it that Matt
Matthew Perry died in the hot
tub that's so sad he was so funny
man I know he was battling an addiction
but I don't know if that had anything to
do with it I think he had a heart attack
they
said in the hot tub and then drowned
which
is
wild um heart goes out to him and his
family and the friends cast you know CU
that's probably weird for
them
um I never met him God he was like 54 or
something imagine that imagine if
[__] Brian C just died that'd be so
insane uh
um yeah rest in
peace I guess Mike Pence dropped out
dude I can't believe Mike Pence was
running first of all hey Mike Pence you
know you you're you're going to lose
100% everyone thinks you're a complete
[__] you know nobody like at all thinks
you're good to do it and everyone who
might will like Trump
better you know Mike Penn's the most
regular looking man I've ever seen in my
life he couldn't look like he plays golf
more and it honestly he was never going
to be president and he
knows man why do people run for
president when they just know they're
not going to do they're not going to
[__] do it what is that thing
remember when the porn star was running
it's like hey you're not going to win
you have balloon
tits you know like [__] probably bill
nairan or something you know what I'm
saying like there's always that one guy
where it's like oh he ran oh yeah okay
cool a comedian ran one time it's like
you're not going to do it why are you
doing it you're spending time on this
and
Money Mike Pence do remember when the
fly landed on his
head and that was it for
him dude
political how [__] shitty are
politics a fly can land on your head
when you're giving an interview and
you're done you know for real like for
real you could just be like so dope and
be like let me sit down for this
interview well I'll tell you what we're
going to do about
taxes and what it is is and you just
keep talking about taxes and there's a
fly just living on your head for a while
and then it goes and you're by the time
you don't the interview they have a
trillion memes and your political career
is over Dude you get out the interview
like I think that went pretty well and
they're like a fly lived on your head
for about 20
minutes and I guys like great I'm
[__]
[Applause]
no you need help getting
up are you able to get up on your own
yes okay I want to leave down I'm mad
Nick why you mad call I just got out of
jail today this time I would suggest
opening the door
so dick I'm wow cathic Gallagher Sor
show me that you can stand
up I
will oh
dude I will dude this woman is so drunk
can you just go inside please Darla so
we can we can roll out and you don't
have to else here at the house to take
care of you I don't need no you just
fell through a door normal people don't
fall through a door you can't even it's
my door she says dude you can't even
like you you're it's so sad when no
matter what you the other person says it
sounds dick because of the situation
you're in you know like well he just
fell through a door like that is what
happened and they're not even trying to
be dick but they're so dick because of
the situation cuz I have to yeah it's
your door was you fell through it no not
out of anger you fell through it normal
people don't fall through door
unbelievable dude the beginning of it
dude look at he broke out my w which
one so
slow the I mean it happened dude it
happened so slow the whole fall happened
during the pause of the last [__]
time in that Billy Joel song where he
pauses and goes in the middle of the
night that last pause is so long that's
how long it took for her to fall out of
the door and into the shrubs
dude
Valley I'm going be looking for
something and then so I'm taking I
lost and then and then she go and then
it
[Music]
dude man I'm mad in the middle of the
night
dude that's so if you know what I'm
talking about you know what I'm talking
about let's watch it again here which
one
look I'm man look I'm so mad dude
somebody please make a [__] thing of
the I guarantee that's is that's that is
so long that that took that's so slow
that it could have happened before the
last pause in the in the middle of the
night song by Billy Joel the whole fall
could happen in that last pause that's
how long it took
H somebody [__] edit that together
[Laughter]
please wow I used to love that song I
when it did that big pause when I was
like 12 I was like [__] yeah that's so
awesome no I was probably like
nine man I'm so
mad am I making sense do you know what
I'm talking about okay you
do which
one kiss in the
screen the way he says are you okay
ma'am like it's Charles Groen are you
okay
[Applause]
ma'am the fire department do you need
help get up why the fire department dude
you know should I call Arby's for you
ma'am do you need some stick sandwiches
no okay we fell through a door normal
people don't fall through a door would
you like some would you like a bazooki
from BJs no okay normal people don't
fall through a door okay
oh
man man I'm so mad she says Mr Smith Mr
Smith locksmith Sydney Australia get
secured babies
041019 4208 go to my page if you want to
purchase a 10-word ad or shout out
holler. christalia dude I love this
app
um Kodak Black and 21 Savage have
[__] beef dude the day has come I
hate that they have beef they're both
really great guys and it sucks that
they're having beef
right let's see what they have to say
you to say 21
Savage 21 to be us to be straight on the
SG twice type
[__] sniper G Slaughter g slaugh g what
[__] or whatever saying but I I remember
a point in time likeit will [__] up
about me like on some [__] like you the
last [__] like that like stay on like
all that good [__] all that other [__]
and then I don't KN like saying Drake
Drake just got a certain like little
effect that he do to [__] and
[__] after the AL together and [__] like
that it just like hey hey dude hey dude
come on
hey hey
man try a little bit you know what I'm
talking about Su with consonant you got
those
we going
do Dr Drake want kind of put all
together my hey guy
dude did you ever have
parents did you have teachers did you
ever have
someone like if I'm friends with
somebody like that I go like this oh my
God
buddy you got you got to you have to you
have to start talking better you know
what I'm talking about like who are the
people in his lot they're just going
like this
yeah all of a sudden [__] just
felt like I'm
saying Oh
[__]
I that [__]
like [__] like you made this [__] like
you like you vocalize it for real for
real on the ground on the on the
internet like you never Ving like
that just waking
up oh
[__] the [__]
the like that's what he said hey this is
beef imagine hearing that and going like
this oh that [__] crossed the
[Laughter]
line when you're talking
about we've got an exclusive with uh
Kodak Black hey who you to say 21 Savage
here we go we got an exclusive interview
with Kodak Black Let's Play a clip of
some of the uh some of the stuff that he
had to say kind of incendiary when it
comes to the the rap game why don't you
have a look
2 21 used to be used to be straight I we
Ving on the SG twice typ
[__] sniper
gaugh okay you know imagine my dad
listening to that so here's 21 Savage's
response which should just be
what response is 2 just goes what but
his response here cuz I did a goddamn
album after I did a album with Drake I
switched
up come on
bro first of all falling
asleep falling asleep falling asleep SW
what what what what supposed to switch
like what supposed to change like dude
these two
guys one just woke up and the other
one's falling
asleep dude unbelievable
did it I ain't grow up with you [__] I
don't know you like that like you rap I
rap I always supported you and
[__] I [__] with your movement like I
[__] with you with what you had on
what you had going on
like talk about switched up you get in
your feelings cuz I'm on club house and
they ask me I can't even believe I'm
doing this dude you should never have if
you have if you have beef with somebody
never say
Clubhouse you
know
hey
children you know what I'm saying meet
me at my tree house dog after dinner if
you allowed outside it get dark early
remember weak ass [__] on [__]
lie you I'm on
clubhouse
that's it you know oh wait wa more here
more all you had to do was say future
cry I pick future over Savage you going
to this deep [__] explanation cuz
God when Savage got oh didum he start
acting funny crying how what the what
change why are they bleeping out the bad
words we can't tell cuz I said I felt
like I beat everybody who was on the
freshman cover I'm posted feel like that
[__] I ain't no [__] I ain't going to
say no another [__] one thing I ain't
going to ever do in my life is say [__]
can beat me in a fight beat me at
nothing I'm not saying I don't give a
dam they put me in the ring with
Shaquille O'Neal they
what okay but there you have it the
exclusive
interview hopefully they they iron out
this beef man I can't I can't have him
be saying much of that you
know
wow
dude to oh
God bro Gavin
Nome twirling around doing that thing
just [__] just taking a China kid to
town
dude and then spanking him for some
reason it's kind of kind of sweet
actually kind of sweet the people are
because they hate him they think like oh
you know [__] this guy but it's totally
nor
normal look look look he he kind of have
some moves do it but then he tripped
he's wearing loafers you
know oh
[Music]
dude okay so [__] you know so
[__] don't stop playing basketball when
you're 40 at least by then because
unless you're doing unless honestly
you're you're playing you know no cuz
even then you should be
retired you know but uh knew
some [__] a [__] and took that China
kid
out
um oh wait one more here RN's in
Connecticut we want you www.pro medstaff
c.com go to my page if you want to
purchase a 10-word ad or shout out Hol
do baby Crystal
dude
good oh here we
go oh is this a this is an ad hold on
here we go a possible case of illegal
dumping in the middle of the street made
one neighbor very upset and he ended up
chasing the person responsible on
Detroit's East Side with no luck and a
big mess on his hand he called us for
help with Edwards tells us what happened
after he on
his we first introduced you to Jeff
Brown during seven Action News at 5 he
witnessed a man boldly dumping large
chunks of wood from a flatbed along
couch on Detroit's East Side Tuesday in
broad daylight look all these trees
Brown says when he confronted the guy
the man took off Brown tells us he
jumped into action got into his car and
tracked down the truck he got a li the
worst [__] John Wick the worst
equalizer number and called police but
the mess remained on the street and no
one had been caught taking action for
brown we did did some digging and found
ehor deich a Warren resident
ehor Park are you [__] [__] me
eor
deich I wish I knew about that name
before my kids were born I would have
named him [__] ehor to Leah what the
driveway would cover his yard svich
claims he curve and the debris
accidentally fell out a little legal to
leave the wood in the street so what I'm
asking is I'm going I you don't have to
ask me and I don't take no orders from
no woman by the
way e
Horse by the way she goes I that was
great she goes I little illegal to leave
the wood in the street so what I'm
asking is I'm going the worst sunglasses
known to man
dude AR Nets you know Ares or whatever
you don't have to ask me and I don't
take no orders from No Woman by the way
by the way I don't take no Ord ERS from
no womenv says she was planning to go
back and clean up the wood but only had
$1 but then a woman asked him to so he's
leaving it there worth of gas so you
were saying that you were going back to
clean up he hored the bage dude yes oh
yes I'm I'm Mr cleanup I'm not Mr Clean
I'm Mr Clean Up some [__]
Vaudeville I mean went on the tiptoes to
say that that last part I'm Mr Clean Up
and I live in Warren and I'm cleaning up
Detroit go figure that one out but
somebody said that they tried to yell at
you to come back and you kept going and
there must have been a woman and I don't
listen to women yelling I tell them to
shut up
well the
dude
Sader his wife left him eight months
ago well he was quite offensive with his
answers to kevich maintained
people remove chunks of wood so many
logs on his front
lawn I lift them all by myself with
nobody else's help old guys disabled
guys black guys white guys polish guys
Ukrainian guys and guys from Mars
also
aliens guys from Mars
also oh okay her oh oh okay from Mars
from Mars yeah that's where I'm from
Mars and police are investigating what
exactly happened out here and whether
svich is responsible or whether he'll
face dude his W his his wife said I'm
leaving you and they got in a huge fight
and she's like oh get out she's like
you're so [__] crazy it's like you're
from Mars and like he can't get out over
it any charges on Detroit's East Side
Tara Edwards 7 Ac news claims he hit a
curb and the debris accidentally fell
out it's a little illegal to leave the
wood the street so what I'm asking is
I'm going I you don't have to ask me and
I don't take no orders from No Woman by
the way by the way I don't take no
orders from no women she was planning to
go back and
clean I live in Warren and I'm cleaning
up Detroit go figure that one out but
somebody said that they tried to yell at
you to come back and you kept going and
there must have been a woman and I don't
listen to women yelling I tell them to
shut up well he
was the most [__] maladjusted man in
the history of of of humans you know it
was no woman that was no saying no
nobody tells me know what to do no
woman go figure that one
out wow this guy's
great wow that guy's
great
H
uh that one's funny sending it to my
friends um
um I dressed up as a Milkman in my
Halloween party and my wife dressed up
for as a uh 50s housewife and it was
cool it was couple's costume people
didn't really know it dude they thought
I was being an ice cream man which
really [__] have made me annoyed and
then I said to people uh why do people
think I'm an ice cream man and people
said well you mean you could be an ice
cream man and I said there's a cow on my
hat and they said well there's milk and
ice cream and I said yeah but that's not
the [__] that's not the thing
honestly I'm a [__] Milkman obviously
dude how crazy is it that people used to
just deliver
milk people used to deliver
milk and also what a racket you didn't
even need
milk you know
you don't need milk you certainly don't
need it to be delivered what a [__]
job it's like a Will Smith movie like a
where a [__] you know he makes those
movies about people with fake jobs like
hitch like what is that movie Hitch a a
guy
who helps people find people that's not
a job dude certainly not from a
guy some like housewife in in in in
Maine would have that job not Will Smith
38 when he shot it you
know how about in the scene when they're
like come on man you going to help me
get laid and he's like whoa that is not
what I do it's like all right bro you
know dude that movie [__] sucks and I
never even seen it I just know that one
scene
um but yeah dude what was I talking
about uh oh yeah so I was a a Milkman
dude all right and it will be past
Halloween when this comes out
but I will be Randall trick-or-treating
with my son who's GNA be Mike wasowski
from Monsters Inc and Billy's GNA be
Sully and my wife was going to be
another person for the for the
um another person from The Monsters Inc
however um she shipped it to the wrong
address so she who knows what she's she
going be her on her own
thing skit face podcast two London boys
create sides splitting comedic sketches
go to my page if you want to purchase a
10-word add uh holler. christalia
dude Halloween's only cool if you have
kids I was thinking about this the other
day I saw a [__] guy dressed up like
for Halloween walking around
alone like a man like
40 and I'm just
like no
you know
like have kids kids dress up and then
also
[__] beyond that nothing like if you
are a lady and you want to hoe it up one
year and be like a sexy Army vet or
whatever the [__] you know with like a
GI Joe hat and your tits all
out fine kids Halloween is for kids and
hoes I I saw a 40-year-old man walking
around dressed as like a
vampire and I'm just
like for what look who's this
for if you're going to a party fine fine
I guess but
also don't have that elaborate of a
costume it's just hurry up if you have
if you're 40 and you're a dude and
you're dressed up and you don't have
kids hurry up and splur in a woman
that's all I'm saying man because it's
weird as [__] you're dressing
up it is and I stand by that dude and
you know I like when people are happy
and you be you ultimately of course but
dude I'll say it again Halloween is for
kids and
hoes
really weird dude like a 50-year-old man
is just going to be a cowboy one day out
of the
Year hey nut in a
woman
uh I'm not in a Halloween although my
wife went all out with the decorations
and I was like okay cool she went all
out with the decorations and that's
great and then it's like I'm now I'm
keeping my tabs on the [__] Christmas
decorations because if that [__] goes
Bonkers she's like I really will go all
out for one holiday a year dude mark my
words we'll see we'll see if we go
Bonkers for
Christmas we'll see dude she says oh
dude she had the nerve to say today
maybe I'll just put up one Christmas
tree this year
dude I go have you ever met
yourself we've got four trees in the
garage what are you just going to leave
leave them there she says me I don't
know maybe we'll go simple hey dude have
you ever met yourself hey look in the
mirror extend your hand shake it that's
you say nice to meet you now decorate
too much because that's what
happens I couldn't even I couldn't even
believe she said
it but she really kills it man I mean
the [__] stuff looked amazing so go
[__] yourself right
uh last one lonely design Co
illustration and design custom work
limited drops go to my page if you want
to purchase a 10-word ad or shout out
holler. christalia dude um thanks for
rock with me that new ads thing is the
[__] I don't have ads and that's how I'm
doing them from now on
um yeah I appreciate you guys listening
and I will tell you this dude
um my special is out so go below and
click the link and go get it
um I am really proud of it and I'm
really excited for you to watch it and
support and don't steal it dude you know
I mean I know there's always ways to get
around it but it's like I worked [__]
hard on that [__]
so get it you know uh thanks a lot and I
appreciate you uh and that's it for
YouTube if you want to listen to the
rest of the episode The uncut episode
the uh adree episode go
to uh patreon.com christalia um that's
how you get that and you can also listen
to We have one episode uh extra a month
that for patreon and you can go get it
over there um and there's so many of
them now if you want to go listen to
them you pay six bucks just all 30 or 40
of them right now that we have in the
past however many months we've did
appreciate you guys thanks a
[Music]
lotu than you
you